dear run you have now reached the
cliffsides overlooking the islands as
you sit here and gaze upon the waters
please read out loud the poem by the
great Scotsman Robert Burns love Leslie
oh were my love young lilac fair with
purple blossoms to the spring
and I a bird to shelter there when we
read on my little wing
how I would mourn when it was torn by
Autumn Wilde and winter rude
but I would sing on wanton wing when
youthful May it's Bloom renewed
[Music]
I don't know what she thought I'd get
out of that
[Music]
laugh with me buddy just with me buddy
don't let her get the best of me but
don't ever let me start
feeling lonely
[Music]
I ever needed you buddy
you know now I really do
but
don't ever let me start
feeling lonely
[Music]
find you will ever
go away
somewhere breakfast nope
oh I don't know
come on
there has never been a sadness that
can't be cured by breakfast food here on
can I ask you a question
sure
it's about April
I don't like to get involved in people's
personal I hurt her feelings
and now she's pissed at me
I feel like if I could just explain
myself she'd understand but she's
avoiding me
it's making me miserable
April's in the hospital sick with the
flu
I knew it I didn't know that is she okay
yeah she's fine you can go visit her
tomorrow morning but don't tell her I
told her I won't
no no no no no
no
well hello there you must be Ron Swanson
or welcome to Casa Ludgate hello Mr
Ludgate ah call me Larry Larry Larry
who's it it's zuzu's boss
Ron Rita Ludgate oh you have no idea how
nice it is to meet you
oh come in for God's sake what can I get
you to drink oh could you take your
shoes off please thank you so much
uh nothing to drink thanks oh okay is
April around uh Zuzu you have a guest
why are you here
come back to work
nah
come back
I want you to come back well I don't
want to come back
the end
I was talking to Andy about you and he
made me realize that I need you back at
work what did he say don't recall fine
I'll come back
good
okay I'm leaving
bye Zuzu
bye Duke silver
my mom has all your albums
I recognize you the day we met
have you told anyone no
good girl
what's that nothing uh
Clear My Throat
oh
John it's red pine
then we're going to put flecked linoleum
over this beautifully preserved naughty
Red Pine most people in this world John
are asked this is the best day I've ever
spent in a government building and
luckily my son was here to share it with
me he now has that satisfied look that
only comes with the pride of Labor
or he pooped
either way well done John
how'd you remember
woof woof
Barb
why here
because this tree reminds me of you it's
strong and quiet
and always here when you need it
or whatever
I've always felt a certain kinship with
April and this is proof that I was
correct
not the nice things she said about me
the fact that I buried a large amount of
gold under that same tree years ago
I have since moved it Mouse Red CD 30
dollars
candy bars fifty dollars fifty dollars
God people here are so cheap April where
have you been over two phone calls came
in unimpeded we're raising money for my
college education Ron
I took a second job back in my old job
do you want a shoe shine it's a hundred
dollars
laugh all you want Kyle I already took
the money out of your wallet oh
good news son
you have just won a Ron Swanson
scholarship
I don't think so I don't remember
applying for anything wrong Swanson
wait are you serious
stop this no
stop or you lose the money
why not I like the kid and I have the
money
one thing I promised myself when I
buried gold in my backyard was that I'd
never be a hoarder or a miser about it
so I
am pregnant
I see I don't understand how we were so
careful I warned you about this standard
birth control methods aren't usually
effective against a Swanson I got about
a million thoughts running around my
head but I really just want to know what
you're thinking
okay here's what I'm thinking
I was going to wait until our
anniversary take you somewhere romantic
perhaps in a canoe most likely in a
canoe
I actually built a canoe for that
purpose but given the news and given my
significant
feelings for you
now seems as good a time as any
Ron Swanson
Diane Lewis
will you marry me
yes
on one condition anything my love ask me
for anything in the world and I'll give
it to you except the destination wedding
just the opposite
we'd both be married before I don't want
anything big or elaborate in fact the
smaller the better I assume you can deal
with that are you kidding as far as I'm
concerned we could go up to the fourth
floor right now
give me here well if you'd have held him
here instead of that conference room I
would have come to more meetings I got
to tell you Leslie establishing this
National Park right next to Pawnee is
quite an accomplishment
this is a fine piece of land you saved
thank you Ron
you want to run it
superintendent of Bryce Canyon retired I
convinced the superintendent of this
park to transfer shuffled a few things
around the point is someone needs to
take care of this place now thought it
should be you
all right
well first of all I would be working for
the federal government your job would be
to walk around the land alone you'd live
in the same town you've always lived in
you'd work outside you'd talk to Bears
next argument there must be dozens of
people gunning for this job I wouldn't
want you to ruffle any feathers am I
even qualified well a few people might
be annoyed but they'll get over it and
as far as your qualifications you're Ron
Swanson
stop being a dummy and accept
when do I start oh today I already
accepted for you I still remember how to
forge your signature let's go meet your
staff
Pawnee National Park Rangers this is Ron
Swanson your new superintendent and boss
Rangers
my name is Ronald Ulysses Swanson
your job and mine is to walk this land
and make sure no one harms it
if you show up on time speak honestly
and treat everyone with fairness we will
get along just fine
though hopefully not too fine as I'm not
looking for any new friends end of
speech
well said
thank you Leslie
you're welcome Ron
okay
time to go to work
laugh with me buddy just with me buddy
don't let her get the best of me buddy
don't ever let me starve
D feeling lonely
[Music]